hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
rebuilding
evolutionary success using inscripta's
onyx
digital genome engineering platform to
ease
and enhance adaptive laboratory
evolution experiments
i'm alexis corrales of labberts and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths and
sponsored by
inscripta for more information about our
sponsor
please visit their website at
inscripta.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button if you have
any trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found
at the top right of the presentation
window or
report your problem like by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left ear screen i'd
like to now introduce our presenter
dr tyson shepard scientist to
applications development
in scripta for a complete biography on
our presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr shepard you may now begin your
presentations
thank you for that introduction um so
like was just said i'm tyson shepard i'm
an application scientist here at
inscripta
uh i began it in scripta about
approximately six months ago
and what really drew me here
to inscriptions into the
platform is to see these capabilities
and really the desires
or the wish that i had these same
capabilities
when i was in graduate school or when i
was doing my postdoc um
i see a lot of potential for these
impacting
uh it's a little like as though there's
a
as you'll see it's a little like um
there's a thesis in every run of the
experiments
and and we're really bringing this to to
all the laboratories um
so my presentation i'll be going over
um both the platform at the start but
then also additionally
uh we'll be showing a an application of
this
in adaptive laboratory evolution
and how we've recapitulated these
libraries so to begin with
um for the overview of the platform
the the fundamental basis of the
platform
is founded on the concept that of
co-delivery of
a guide rna a crispr and a
donor template all in one that then can
simultaneously be
barcode tracked inside the cell
um and that barcodes then allows you to
then segment out the populations and
and later do all kinds of interesting
discoveries
um and really
built on that fundamental basis is the
concept that we want to
democratize biological engineering uh
to really bring this biological
engineering to every lab
that we can and to do so we're not just
helping design these barcoded
editing plasmids we're simultaneously
also designing elegant and efficient
hardware
and software that uses the overall
process
uh a single box that will provide
you get the reagents and then it does
the crisper editing
and then you retrieve the cells for your
subsequent experiments
uh and then this is our technology is
also based on
uh the crispr enzyme mad seven which is
similar to cpf1 in a way
but is quite different um and
has some unique features and is also
capable of of sort of freedom of use the
sequence is available
and and labs can can use this readily
so historically uh
the way that mutations have kind of been
played out in molecular biology is that
you can kind of split this apart into
two different axes which is
you can edit a small number of genomic
locations
for example uh do gene knock-ins or
or knock-outs and then you can do
subsequent
protein engineering at certain locations
you can also maybe on a different axis
you can think of
the variety of different um edit types
that can be made so you can do
whole pathway engineering you can do
this protein engineering you can do side
directive mutagenesis
but those are all low in the number of
locations that can be made
simultaneously you can have a
relatively low number of types of edits
that can be made but
across larger genomic landscapes um
what would be fascinating is
imagine the capability of being able to
do genome-wide engineering rather than
individual pathway or protein
engineering and then you can explore the
entire breadth of what's allowable by
the genome
just by having the capabilities of
additing and
historically this has just been
compressed away from
capable just because of the inability to
track so many different modifications
well here because of the software that's
being made and the
automated aspect of the instruments
combined with the power of barcode
tracking we can actually explore the
full potential of genome engineering
so not just in one locus anymore not
just
of one type of modification that can be
done but really anything
that you can imagine can be spread out
across the genome
so to do so we we kind of uh stick to
that
engineering con concept which is the
design generate
test learn cycle so
really the fundamental begins with that
design we have this easy to use web
portal
to be able to make your modifications
uh and interact with the genome in ways
that you've never
had the capability to do before this
allows you to then
engineer in modifications into your
into your cells but then after
once you order the reagents after a few
weeks
a kid arrives that you then load into
your instrument
run the instrument runs and then you're
able to
get out like a single tube that contains
your edited cell population
then you can take that tube and go do
your experiments you can do your
selection
experiments and and do
all sorts of downstream phenotypic based
experiments
and then come back and and you can use
sequencing to be able to track those
barcodes or the edits on the genome
and then you can pull that back into
our software that we will then help
analyze for you
and provide the results from these
editing experiments
so that then we can help you parse
through
all of this data that you'll be getting
off of the
off of the experiment
so at the start we'll be offering
um both editing and e coli and
saccharomyces cerevisiae yeast strain uh
as and and then we have some uh inscript
as standard
strains both e coli and yeast uh
that we can work with quite readily
and then we're also having some
capabilities of bringing on custom
strains that are from uh
from from clients that are provided from
clients and and being able to have the
same
operational uh infrastructure come in
onto your own
strain of interest so for right now
though we're starting with e coli
and yeast and right now we're also at uh
at launch we'll have one edit per cell
but we'll be expanding in the future
the edit types that can be done are
insertions deletions and substitutions
and per library per per run you can have
from 100 to 10 000 different edits
across your genome
if you're using e coli and from 100 to 6
000 in yeast
so large landscape to play with
per run per per sample
we will typically see 30 percent
edited cells that's complete and
intended edits on those cells
and that's somewhat variable just based
on the type of edit that you're doing
uh just how large the insertion is for
example
and so forth can have an impact on that
to from the time to order to receive
the the reagents
is about three to four weeks and then
the instrument time that it's running is
only one
approximately one to three days before
you get this
output vial that contains all of your
edited cells
so as i mentioned that there's a wide
diversity of
possible editing types both in coding
and
non-coding regions uh so those
just to get an idea to to have in your
head about the different
editing types that can be made in
non-coding coding regions for example
you can do
uh up to 61 base pair insertions and
those includes a wide series of
promoters you might think about as
as being one area of interest so you can
do an insertion
outside the coding region you can
certainly do insertions within coding
regions
you can also do substitutions so here i
show an example of
a 38 base pair substitution of
terminators
and that then is of course swapping out
or replacing
the nucleotides with those that you've
programmed in
additionally in coding regions now i
just highlight all of those things that
are still
capable in coding regions but we we also
you know
have proven out the capabilities of
generating knockout strains by triple
stop
codon insertions uh into
or across the genome and we can also do
saturation mutagenesis
across coding regions so you can really
explore
the the breadth of a protein of interest
that you're studying
to see how the cell responds to it or to
see
variants of a particular
particular protein within cells
so one way to think about this or or
a great way to kind of conceptualize
what we're doing
is that we're taking the sort of the old
paradigm
of having to make a 96 well plate
with individual edits
by introducing the guide rna and the
donor template into each of those
individual wells
that aren't combined together or linked
together
and so they've by necessity been
had to have been separated into these
wells
and with our technology now the way to
think about it is that we've taken that
96 partitions those 96 different wells
we've condensed all of that biochemical
information that you can get out of that
down into the single cell so that every
single cell becomes
its own little reaction space we're
still
delivering a single guide rna with the
donor repair but then additionally with
this barcode allows us to track the
individual cell populations which then
allows it to be very similar to this 96
well partitioned format
so we can do if you remember we can do
10 000 different custom designs
on a single run on any uh
across a population of the e coli for
example
what this leads to is millions of
precisely engineered single cells
that you can then take downstream and
generate the phenotypic
response from all of these
mutations that you've made into the
individual cells
so now i want to highlight an
application of this particular
technology and that's to adaptive
laboratory evolution so
we've been working with uh with marcus
regards
a leader in the field of adaptive
laboratory evolution
to obtain a set of
mutations that are found through ale
experiments
and then recapitulate
these using the onyx technology
and i'm going to present that data here
so if you're not familiar adaptive
laboratory evolution or al experiments
is a high throughput way of being able
to
generate mutations and strains
due to or when you um have them
assaulted with some chemical that would
otherwise inhibit their growth
so it's a very powerful approach that
under continuous growth in these stress
environments you can get these mutations
and then
by the powers of next generation
sequencing
it really enables you to then go into
that population
and uh identify the mutations the
single nucleotide polymorphisms or
insertions or deletions
that are then discovered and that can
then have applications both in
biotechnology
for the evolution of strains that
function under a given chemical stress
but then also can give rise to new
biochemical information
however the ale it has a couple of
drawbacks to it in that it's time
consuming
it can take weeks to run an experiment
up to
kind of tongue-in-cheek it can it can
run for decades to be able to get
explore the mutation space it does
require typically
uh rebuilding that uh
strain for downstream characterization
uh for new biochemical understanding as
well as having that engineered custom
strain
then it also um ale is
fairly restrictive in its evolutionary
flow because it's moving linearly along
a path of evolution
so it doesn't get to explore the full
breadth of
of being able to try multiple different
uh modifications because it's
uh just moving linearly along what wins
uh kind of
a random walk in a way um the inscripta
onyx platform actually enables
a couple of interesting features that
can add on to these al experiments
so it's a high throughput method
ultimately of generating
a massive number of variants that's
that can then act as a precisely
engineered initial population
so you can come at this with uh with the
knowledge of the mutations that you
do uh want to study and uh
and that's sort of what's shown here in
in this work
but then you can simultaneously use this
to ask a lot of new questions because
then you can have your
starter population that you know
precisely what you're starting your ale
library with and then you can make these
modifications and then grow out from
there so that you're no longer
restricted to that strict evolutionary
linear path so we
we really think that this provides a lot
of power to the
ale workflow
so for the um overall workflow of the
inscriptive
onyx platform is that then
you work with the interface the user
interface
to design and generate new modifications
that you want made to the genome
in three to four weeks you get your
reagents plus an additional day of
editing
and then you have a tube of engineered
cells that you can then take
for downstream selections you then
process those for sequencing you can
upload those sequences then for analysis
of your your barcode selections that
you've done
and learn new things about your uh
experiments of interest that then can
feed back
and you can actually then go through
this cycle multiple times
and generate a new powerful strain for
the
chemical of interest for example
so in this case we did a high throughput
rebuilding of ao variants so again
working with
marcus air herrgarden and his lab
we generated a list of 372 different
uh ale variants that were previously
found
through um by uh growth within
11 different chemicals of those 11
different chemicals there were two
chemicals to note here which is chomeric
acid
and isobutyric acid those um
then the variants were taken forward and
used
on our design platform to be able to
rebuild those variants
on our using the onyx technology
further because of the wide space of
what's available for modifications
we might also be interested in what
would happen if we inserted mobile
elements
or made deletions or knockouts within
the genome
of those same genes or other others that
have been shown to be
modified so of these 372
variants that were that were done those
are across
all 11 chemicals and not just cumeric
acid and isobuturic acid but this is a
across all the different chemicals so we
can really
test widely the biochemical information
from each of those
this brought us to a total of 992
individually designed
and trackable edits that are going to be
made to the genome
so this is now an actual picture of what
you might see when you're
using the inscriptive platform to edit
your
genomes so it's a
very intuitive uh gui interface here
where you can interact with the genome
i almost think about it as it's a little
bit like if you were able to
ssh or telnet into the cell and be able
to
you know interact with it or program it
um
just it it's sort of that that nice to
work with
um then you can make your insertions
deletions and substitutions
and then they show up both in the e coli
coordinate system for example on the
left
as well as we have a genome viewer that
allows you to then
zoom in and be able to see the edits
that you are
planning to make to both ensure that
those of the edits that you want as well
as be able to in real time
get feedback for which edits would be
most likely to be
functional within the cells
so then as i said downstream from that
is once you get your tube of cells then
you take that on to
sequencing and uh because of the
sort of the magic of the barcode that
allows you through sequencing
to be able to investigate which variant
is actually
present within your pool then
so each of the cells are going to
contain a different guide rna donor
and barcode by the analysis of the
barcodes
we can really map those back onto the e
coli coordinate system
and on the edits that are made this is
kind of then you know flashing back to
the
the gui it aligns perfectly well with
the edits that were made and it turns
out that we
see within our sample when grown in lb
uh 92 are observed and some of those
that drop
out some of those unobserved are just
potentially due to
partially to cell viability so some of
the knockouts that we make are going to
be within the
transcription machinery that just might
simply
not be compatible and you might see the
same thing and that alone is interesting
biochemical information
but we can then take this fully
functional library with 92 percent of
the edits that we've made
and carry that forward and be able to
continue to track those individual
barcodes
under different chemical assaults so
let's do that now
so we take this on the engineer
population
we take that on to the next step which
is our selection experiment
so in this case we um provide then
a selection and then goes on to
sequencing
so we take that single tube of library
that contains
all of those edits within it the 992
different edits
and we set up the experiment as such and
we
have our control our base control which
is the m9 glucose that's with no
addition of chemicals
then using again marcus aeroguard and
and his labs work using concentrations
of camaric acid
and isobutyric acid of 7.5 grams per
liter which is enough to
start to have a growth defect we also
uh put the same uh inoculate from
that same pool into the cameric acid and
isolaric acid additionally to
be able to test whether or not it's a
salt effect of
any of the growth we see we also put it
into nacl 400 millimolar
and we spike it into lb to see under
conditions where there's no restrictive
growth like there would be under m9
so now when we have this selection
experiment
and we then do barcode analysis and and
get the sequencing from that information
that then feeds onto the next step which
is really where the
the true joy of science comes right
which is in
the analysis and learning that we get
from the data
and then the new biochemical knowledge
that we can gain from such experiments
so um that analysis population the
first thing that that we did was to
assess the quality and reproducibility
of the data
we then identify looking at differences
between isobutyric acid versus
cumeric acid versus the m9
media to be able to investigate what are
the mutations that make the most
difference within
each of the growth populations we look
for these trends of enrichment and
depletion
that then give us biochemical
information about the individual edits
that have been made
and their performance within that
particular chemical
and then we um functionally assess these
enriched and depleted genes
and that's where we gain our new
biochemical insights and
add to the existing knowledge of these
of these individual strains
so this is one of the um graphs that
that that's common with this data it's a
plot of the log
of the relative abundance of a bar codes
in a particular sample after growth
versus
in in a chemical versus in the control
sample
so relative abundance is how much of the
individual bar code is in the entire
pool of barcodes
um and so this each of these four plots
are the
four different chemicals that we tested
against against along the x-axis
is the relative the log 10 relative
abundance
in m9 so you can see an interesting
effect for nacl
you see that it's a quite condensed
along a line
this indicates there's not much there's
a significant amount of correlation
of each individual at its growth within
both nacl
versus m9 alone in lb it gets dispersed
a little bit
and you can really start to see
additional dispersion with the cameric
acids
and isobutyric acids and so
we're starting to see like the
populations
fall away or become enriched in these
and that's where
these edits become can can become quite
interesting
as we look at this so this gives us an
overall snapshot of the correlation and
outliers and those outliers are the ones
that then we would want to
look at for effects within a particular
chemical
so each of these experiments as i
mentioned was done in
biological triplicates with the
exception of n9 which was done
uh in replication six replications
um along the diagonal you see the
extreme correlation between any given
experiment
and within the triplicate measurement
it's highly correlated
and you can see examples then of
like for example m9's behavior and nacl
we saw that it fell
well within a line and here this is now
the spearmint correlation matrix that
shows this correlation
is a measure of of what you're seeing
and really you see that high correlation
coming through with that nacl to m9
conditions so all the strains are
behaving
the same way whether or not it's
irrespective of the presence of
nacl in this instance you see the
dispersion start to take place
within isobutyric acid and kumeric acid
so you can kind of see that escape away
from the m9
but then when you look at chumaric acid
and isolaric acid responses individually
they're not very well correlated at all
to
the growth response for every one of
those individual cells that were edited
so if we just look at that relative
abundance plot that log relative
abundance plot again we can see that
dispersion
as well that there's a number of
outliers between these two different
conditions
one additional way of looking at this
same kind of separation of data is by
doing
a principal component analysis so this
is the pca analysis of just the 372 ale
edits
they as you can see they cluster
on the replicate so these are all the
replicates plotted out here and they
cluster
in distinct locations within the pca
analysis
so there's a clear separation of
each of the individual chemical stresses
that have been
placed on this so the population is
behaving differently and with the
replicates you can have a high
confidence
moving forward that you're getting
reproducible data so not only are they
behaving distinctly but they're
reproducibly
very nicely reproducibly um
behaving in a distinct manner and so
then this is
now the um these are really like looking
at the
entire population of all of the
uh cells within the individual um
stress that was placed on them
so then what we can also do is look at
the individual
edit that was made um and
be able to see any biochemical patterns
that
might show up so this is an example this
is on then the e coli coordinate system
maps all of the edits and so each of
these
dots on this on this radial ply
are representative of one edit that was
made
and this is now an average of the
triplicates that were done and along
the radial direction outwards is a
measurement of the enrichments
of the uh of the edit or depletion
so the zero line is in blue is
surrounding this radial plot
and then the distance away from that is
representative
of the treatment abundance
which you saw divided by the control
abundance and then it's the log of that
and that gives us an enrichment score of
that treated condition
so this is for cumeric acid you can see
that there are certain
mutations um within the cell population
that give a rise of or an enrichment
within the camaric acid
and there's a number of ulcer mutations
that are depleted out in cameric acid
response so they become more susceptible
than m9
which is the control they become more
susceptible
with these mutations being made
then as plotted here um you can kind of
see that the reproducibility of this
data is so pristine that there's
fairly few points that show up but this
is a p-value of
those those that are colored your
p-value of less than 0.001
so it's quite reproducible and the
point size here is then indicates the
actual
number of counts so you can have an edit
which might have low counts but be
significantly enriched
but simultaneously um it's more it's
possibly even more exciting when you see
multiple counts
um showing up and also significantly
enriched so this then is looking at
isobutyric acid
response rather than the camaric acid
response or side by side
and you can actually already start to
see that there's significant differences
in responses uh between the two
different chemical stresses that are
that are observed here so for example i
might point your eye to
like the four million base pair region
which is
kind of maybe close to the origin of
replication you can see
within there there's some edits that are
quite different where it's
in significantly enriched and isobutic
acids and
some that are rich and some are depleted
in the cumeric acid response
so how do you unpack this data
you know with all of this data there's
really great plots that can be made with
this
another common plot that you might have
seen if you've come from the rna
sequencing world
is like a volcano plot um
is sometimes called so in this plot
is the the
effect of enrichment or depletion
is essentially made along the x-axis so
that's the log of the abundance of the
cumeric
acids uh barcodes over the m9
response and so on the left is cameric
acid on the right and green is
isobutyric acid
and then on the y-axis is the log
of the p-value and and so you can have
higher
confidence than those that are high on
the y-axis
so really what we see on the um what we
see on the
let's focus on the camaric acid for a
moment is
i've highlighted here a number of
individual mutations that were made
in the annotated genes here
as being significantly more resistant to
cameric acid pressure
when these modifications were made as i
mentioned each of these points is an
individual mutation so you can see
for example that rpoa is showing up in
multiple different time
uh multiple different locations so those
are different mutations within
the edited cell population
and and we can just track those uh and
and so then you see with acetyric acids
uh the same type of thing where you can
have uh rpoc or rpob
uh that are showing up that can have a
substantial effect
on the growth or essentially is enriched
within
isobutyric acid we see that
rpoa is not showing up as one of those
edited populations that's highly
enriched
so let's focus in on this the rpo
a is a part of that rna polymerase
machinery
and so here i've actually drawn out even
more to make it clearer
is some of the actual mutations in rpoa
that that chameric acid response gave us
and so these individual point mutations
that are made um are you know we can do
insertions which i've shown that
are recapitulated from an al experiments
uh
individual point mutations and and then
um also
those individual point mutations can be
either enriching or depleting and we see
that in this case is that rpoa
has some mutations that are enriched and
others that are depleted in
the chumeric acids and so
what we're seeing here is that then also
on the right i might point out is then
the isobutyric acid
which has that rpoc which is also part
of that same complex the
rna polymerase machinery um that rpoc
is showing up as highly enriched in
isobutyric acid
but rpoa and and some modifications
rpob are actually then depleted within
the isobutyric acid response
so this is sort of one of the powerful
things is that so far we've been looking
at
population-wide responses when put under
chemical strain
but this gives us something new to think
about which is
how can i use this technology to look at
individual
proteins and investigate responses
for mutations and substitutions that are
made within an individual protein
so what we did here is we actually
mapped all of the modifications of the
rpoa
from the camaric acid response onto the
pdb
structure so this shows the
three-dimensional
structure uh on the right of
the rna polymerase and highlighted in
weak color
on the on the right is the rpoa
subunit of the rays
and on the left we show a volcano plot
again
but now this is the individual point
with all individual point mutations
within
the rpo a machinery so
in color in green are those
mutations that were made that made the
cell
that those modifications were made in
more tolerant to cumaric acid
and on the left of that plot in red are
those mutations that were made that made
it less tolerant
and just just to help
clarify better is that in gray our dots
were was the isopateric response so
in almost all cases uh as you can see in
gray
is that the isometric response was uh
depleting
with all modifications but the incumaric
acid some were
like improved tolerance and some words
of bleeding
mapping those on now to the right
structure with that rpoa
in shown in wheat we can see how those
mutations would impact the amino acids
and that gets colored now onto the
rna polymerase and so we see that
the mutations that make the
cell more tolerant to comeric acids
are colored in green and clustered into
a specific region
on the n-terminal domain of the rna
polymerase
meanwhile those mutations that make it
less tolerant to chomeric acid
are clustered on the c-terminal domain
what's
known about the rna polymerase is that
that n-terminal domain
is uh typically associated with sub-unit
assembly and dimerization of
of the rpo um a and then
the rest of the subunit is coming
together so it's kind of a structural
protein in a way
meanwhile that c-terminal domain is
responsible for interacting with
translation factors and giving that
stress response
so one can imagine that the negative
tolerance that's
associated with mutations on the
c-terminal domain
might be because it's disrupting its
capability of having that stress
tolerance
from uh from interacting with these
transcription factors
yet the um the more tolerant mutations
might make it easier to assemble or it
might very well be a binding site for
example of cameric acid
so that's where more biochemical
characterization might come into play
but it does give you a sense of the
power of what can be done when you're
doing these type of assays to be able to
do genome-wide screening for
modifications
and being able to dig down into very
specific biochemical questions
to then achieve new hypotheses
uh that you can carry forward maybe for
drug screening
maybe for structural biology and being
able to
uh identify new variants that you might
be interested in testing
or for just simply better understanding
the evolutionary pathway
that you typically see in your own ale
experiments
and see that this is now playing out in
a way that we can
get a snapshot across many different
modifications simultaneously
so i also want to give you a sense that
you know we've mostly been talking about
just those ale specific
modifications uh that were discovered
through the expl
experiments but we also have this rich
data set of
frame shifts that were made by mobile
element insertions
as well as deletions that we can kind of
test loss of function for those
ill mutations that are made but also
simultaneously
get a whole new deep understanding of
when those proteins are knocked out
what's their own behavior within
within the same kind of chemical stress
and you can see that some of those
modifications
are more resistant when you put the
deletions and frameshifts in
you can kind of see that that those data
sets alone are
are rich and provide a wellspring of
their own biochemical information that
comes from those
generally what you can do then is kind
of looking at that whole population of
deletions
and frameships plus the al edits is that
you can
um sort those this is just broadly
sorting those out into different
functions so metabolism
membrane response regulation is it a
part of the replication machinery the
transcription machine or the translation
machinery or is it transport or is there
other
and really one more thing that we you
know just don't have time to talk about
are all the unknown genes that come up
in these ale experiments where this can
give new insights into
the function of unknowns of genes with
unknown function
so the so-called wyom for example so
here plotted on the
y-axis is at the abundance again the log
of the abundance so that enrichment
score
and then along the x-axis are these
categories of different
and so then each of these strips are
individual genes within
the study you can kind of see global
trends so for example modifications in
the membrane
or in the replication or also in the
the other category are generally
depleting what for the cameric acid
response but in transcription
as we've already seen within the rpla
story
is transcription can have a substantial
effect for enriching
modifications within within the
transcription machinery
so we really see that capitulated here
and this can be done for multiple
different
uh stresses than like for isobutyric
acid and we can see the effects
and that gives you a sense of what are
the impacts of
globally of the different machinery
within the cell
further this is uh also quite helpful in
that
it's these modifications if you remember
were recapitulated from an original
library that were generated from the ale
experiments and here we see some of
these same modifications showing up
in our own response from our onyx edits
so every other column there's the
isobutyric
acid from the ale study this is the most
common is pykf
modification the next most common is the
rpob
edit that's being made so these are
these are show up again and again in ale
experiments under isoproteric stress
we actually then see our pob an
individual point mutation
can have a substantial effect on the
enrichments of the isobutyric acid so in
this dark color is
um eightfold or greater um
enrichment in isopteric acid compared to
that m9 control
and again in in lighter blue here now is
a four-fold enrichment a greater than
four-fold enrichment
and so we see that response with a
couple of different mutations within
rpoc
along with the isobutyrate onyx column
that show up that's also seen within
that al library that
a couple of times rpoc modifications
show up
with chumeric acid again our
mutations within rho show up repeatedly
in seven out of the eight replicates in
the ale experiments whereas
in the onyx platform we see that
mutation
within rho we see a specific mutation
that provides the most
uh tolerance in cameric acid so again
the dark color is indicative of
a greater than eight-fold
enrichments over over m9 control
we also see these other genes of
interest showing up rpoa
and you can see that there are a few
examples
of genes of unknown functions that do
show up as well
that gives us a better biochemical
insight as well
so we kind of see that recapitulation of
those ale results already
but we also see the diversity that this
engineered population actually allows us
to investigate single point mutations
simultaneously with being able to
broadcast a wide net of modifications so
that we can really capture
an entire landscape for a stress
response
for a given given chemical
so the overall workflow here that we
talked about is
we take that edited cell we either can
take
isolated um take it to isolated cells
and look at responses or take whole
pools
samples is what we did in this case and
then we can
down screen down downstream of that we
can screen
for um either
phenotypic responses with direct
detection
of um behaviors of the cells or proteins
and then we can also take all of those
to sequencing and do
a genotype on it and so we're really
finding ways to bring
together wrap together the phenotypic
response with the genotype of the
underlying genotype
and that allows us you know to open the
doors to
all these new discoveries
so some of those top hits for that uh
diverse library that was generated
um you can imagine then it can be
brought forward
multiple rounds so that if you're really
interested in
getting the best possible stream to
behave under a compound
you can carry this same workflow through
and feedback those modifications and
this really stretches its legs when we
introduce
our combinatorial editing workflow which
will allow multiple different edits to
be able to be made within a genome
simultaneously
and then you can build upon those
modifications that you've seen
uh previously and see
increases in stress tolerance to to a
fantastic levels as you make these
modifications and really broadcast
mutations across the entire genome
so we've really tried to um
in this study and and within the actual
onyx platform
we've shown that you know we've made it
so that you can make
thousands of modifications uh within an
edited pool of
cells that we're trying to make easy for
you to be able to just do a
push button kind of service of being
able to
broadcast these mutations across the
genome
this particular study we showed that we
can recapitulate
ill study using uh
modifications that were found within
previous ale experiments
but then also really that showcases the
ability to then take that engineered
population that you know precisely
what's in there
and carry that forward for subsequent al
experiments
or subsequent onyx editing experiments
to be able to
combinatorial edit a few in the future
um and then finally this took
just you know a few weeks at the bench
when we were able to recapitulate this
uh this study that was you know took
several months to be able to carry out
under stress tolerance so we've really
eased the
overall workflow as well with our single
edited
population as well so i think this
really addresses
all of the needs of the ale studies and
i think it could really
advance this entire uh field as well as
as you saw
the impacts on structural biology and
screening
so thank you very much for listening
and i would be happy to take any
questions now
thank you dr shepherd for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is going to be a two-part question dr
tyson
how applicable your is your technology
is
to the genome editing in non-standard
microbes
and is this platform compatible with
genome engineering in eukaryotes such as
yeast
all right thanks thanks a lot for um the
questions coming in
um so this one is a great question uh
thanks for asking it
um so at the time of
uh when the instrument is being rolled
out
we are principally supporting e coli
both internal strains as well as
capabilities to explore alternative
strains
but then also we're supporting yeast
in particular so s288c
strain is sort of the standard strain
that we're working with but
then also we're interested moving
forward with
expanding and testing other e coli and e
strains and
expanding over time
great now our next question is are you
engineering the population
first or are you creating a true mutant
population
through ale that can be analyzed on the
back end
okay thanks that's another great
question um
the these this presentation was kind of
highlighting both of those applications
however
to to clarify is that the library that
was
that the data comes from here was
generated
originally from an ale dataset so they
were originally all these mutations were
raised in an
ale experiment against multiple
different chemicals
but then we took those sets of edits
and then engineered them directly into
the population so
the population and the data that you're
seeing here
is actually composed of an engineered
population
and then then subjecting that population
to these two specific chemicals
now how do you control cross
contamination during your high
throughput analysis
so this comes from um you can use
amenable technologies to um
next generation sequencing to ensure
that there's not cross-contamination
within the actual
um sequencing uh to the limits or
capabilities of the sequencer
that you're using um in this case since
our
main or our our major readouts in this
particular study was
barcode amplicon so that means that
there's
a bar code that's present not on the
genome but separate from the genome
that's of a length scale that's easily
read out
with aluminum-based sequencing and then
from cross-contamination we don't have
to worry so much from
different cultures but then those are
each prepped individually and then
sent for sequencing with different
indices
yeah thank you that's your question
we do have time for some more questions
but i do want to remind our audience
that those questions we are unable to
answer today and those that come in
during the on-demand present
uh during the on-demand period excuse me
will be answered
by dr shepard via the email address that
you provided at the time of registration
so let's continue on to our next
question what is the best use of your
technology
what is the best use of your technology
would be for a higher protein or
enzyme production uh that's a nice
question
uh thanks for asking that um that's
that's a application that i think is
particularly
interesting for this uh technology
because you've
seen even with the the data shown here
that you can make variants within
a protein itself you could imagine that
you might be able to apply this
technology both for
codon optimization of a particular gene
that's integrated
into a genome you can modify
promoters we've done that in other apps
that have been
spoken about that you might
enjoy going back and reviewing so you
can modify promoters
ribosomal binding sites um and
and mrna but then also simultaneously
you can make genome-wide modifications
that can
possibly boost uh you know the potential
of protein production
by changing the capabilities of the
the metabolic rates or amino acid
production
or even the translation machinery itself
can be modified to allow for
increased expression um another thing
that's sort of of interest with enzyme
production is
that you might see some improved effects
just by
increasing the or
allowing for production of the
resistance to the chemical that's being
produced so all of these are possible
and
it's a great application to explore
thank you let's go to our next question
it looks like this one is a two-part
question as well
i'm having a little difficulty
understanding the generation of
libraries
does onyx generate the barcodes that
makes this so powerful
powerful for constructing genome scale
libraries
and does it synthesize the dna itself
and transform it or is it really just a
design platform
that's an excellent question thanks for
the opportunity to clarify
um on this so the barcodes are
are not something that you'll directly
interact with that's something that's
automated and through the design
platform itself
um those barcodes are just right used
for the actual readouts then
the actual instrumentation is
not synthesizing the dna what you'll
receive
when you order a library is a set of
components that you'll
plug into the instruments and the
instrument takes care of all of the cell
handling
itself such that you don't
you put in these components and kind of
press the start button you know
i'm kind of what we're generalizing here
but uh
it's then automates the entire process
and workflow for growing out those
uh making those edits growing out and
then you'll receive a test tube back
with
a library of those edits in the actual
cell culture
but the barcodes themselves are distinct
and separate from the
from from from on the genome they're off
the genome and can be tracked
for subsequent sequences
thank you now dr tyson our next question
is can you remind me how you made the is
mobile element insertion
and how long of the edit can be made
yeah good question um so the
length of the edit that can be inserted
is up to 61 base pairs and we have
as i mentioned a minute ago we we have a
promoter library
um that's the subject of a former
presentation you can
you can see by um dan held for example
who's talked about
uh such the uh such an application uh so
insertion links can be up to 61. in this
case
the mobile element here uh we're we're
really just taking it kind of as a
synthetic mobile element so this was
35 bases so that would induce a frame
shift
but it's similar to sites where mobile
elements were
introduced within the ale studies which
is a common
motif that that occurs and so we wanted
to take advantage of
that and still use uh and and still use
the
breadth of our platform so i here we
were just using synthetic
uh you know maybe put quotes around it
mobile elements
um to get that breadth of edits
thank you and it looks like we have time
for one more question
so earlier you mentioned that an
approach with onyx can be different than
ale
how can this approach take a different
path than a linear introduction of edits
oh that's an awesome question thank you
um
so the way that that occurs is
that because you're starting with an
engineered population so
you know going through the workflow
mentally is that you went on to the
portal you've made your designs and
interacted with the genome
and come up with a set of designs that
you're interested in
be it of a particular protein or set of
proteins or pathways that you're
interested in but
maybe across the whole genome you can
then get the tube off the onyx
instrument that has that edited pool
population
and by sequencing them
and the way the technology works is that
now you have an engineered starting
population
that you still know exactly what's in it
just like
when you're starting your experiment
from a clonal isolate that's what you
really care about is that you know
exactly what you're starting from
here you still know exactly what you're
starting from it's just now you can then
go on to do an
ale experiment with uh with you know up
to 10 000 different
edits across the genome so you can
really get like a full breadth
of not just the single edits like what
was shown here
but then you can do those that
simultaneous ale experiments and raise
new mutations against the edited
population that you can go back and
track
thanks that's a great question thank you
thank you again dr shepard do you have
any final comments for our audience
no thanks a lot for for listening and
um please email me or let me know
if you have any questions about the
technology uh
and then as mentioned we'll um hopefully
be in touch if you've
asked the question that i haven't had
time to get to so thank you very much
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
like dr shepard said questions that we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by dr shepard via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
as a reminder there will be a survey at
the end of the presentation
and we look forward to your feedback we
would like to once again thank dr
shepard for his time today and his
important research
we would also like to thank labbert and
our sponsor in scripta
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now until next time
bye-bye